I'm gonna get so many followers never
never doing that again I'm never doing
that again
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie these are gonna
be my spider-man far from home deleted
scenes in the alternate ending there
were a lot of questions about other
things that happen during the movie
people pointing out Mysterio popping up
secretly standing next to spider-man
when he was getting on the plane one of
the best things about that character is
that he totally messes with your mind so
we'll break it all down and because
we're getting ready to drop spider-man
far from home on digital and blu-ray
we'll do a giveaway for that all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best spider-man 3 Marvel
phase 4 theory on the video big spoiler
warning for spider-man far from home
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet because we'd be talking
about very specific details the end of
the movie the two alternate endings
starting with number 15 there was a
deleted scene of Iron Man as you all
probably suspected leaving a message for
Peter on the Edith glasses that he would
have seen the first time he puts them on
and activates them it would have been
the exact same type of message that Iron
Man recorded at the end of Avengers
endgame remember he recorded that
message on his helmet that he played for
everyone it was meant to be this really
hopeful moment during that sad funeral
but again that's just hero Gagan
journeys the end this would have been a
continuation of that like just telling
Peter look you are the future I'm
leaving this to you because I believe in
you
and also sassing him a little bit
telling some jokes like the note that he
left explaining why he named the glasses
Edith even dead I'm the hero 14 there
was gonna be way more scenes in New York
City at the beginning of the movie just
to give you an idea for how the city had
changed since everybody come back from
the snap everybody dealing with
everything like in this area of Queens
they have the shelter people dealing
with being homeless they tell those
funny stories that was going to be way
more of that stuff at the beginning of
the movie 13 the scrolls if you can
believe it had way more to do with
Mysterio's plot in deceiving everyone
trying to get to Edith glasses but they
got rid of that after they decided that
it was just way too many twists in the
final version of the movie that we all
saw in theaters you have Talos and his
wife they say that they're basically
standing in for Nick Fury and Maria hill
because they both wanted to go on
vacation nick fury's got his own Tahiti
simulation going on on the sword Space
Station with all those shield
agents around him or sword agents we
should say I keep thinking of Nick Fury
as being director of shield but now we
should say he's director of sword after
the Captain Marvel movie Kevin Feige was
like well yeah we made these Scrolls
good but there are bad scrolls out there
that would do something like The Secret
Invasion comic book storyline so in the
original version of spider-man far from
home those evil Scrolls were just trying
to do more to get their hands on the
eateth glasses and it was just another
one of those Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase
5 teaser things like you have Scrolls in
the background slowly trying to take
over the earth because of what they did
with the final version of the movie you
probably heard that Easter Egg Kree
sleeper cells so now it sounds like
they're Secret Invasion twist is going
to be built on the idea that the Kree
the pink-skin Kree are actually gonna
try and take over planet Earth
eventually during Marvel phase five or
whenever they decide to do that number
12 in the first alternate ending to the
movie this was gonna be a major major
twist at the end they were gonna say
that Mysterio had been a scroll this
whole time but part of the reason why
they didn't do that as you can assume is
that he was already double-crossing
Peter because he's a villain trying to
get the Edith glasses he was already
trying to double-cross Nick Fury but
they weren't really clear if in that
original version when Mysterio was an
evil scroll trying to hide that from
them the whole time a sort of triple
cross situation if in that same scenario
Talos would have also been still
masquerading as Nick Fury or if it would
have been scroll Mysterio trying to
deceive the real Nick Fury things got
way too confusing in that version of
events they decided it was one too many
twists for the movie the twist of
Mysterio and all the fake news at the
end of the film was enough for them so
that's just why they stopped it at that
11:00 Donald Glover was gonna have a
cameo as Aaron Davis returning in all
those New York City scenes at the
beginning of the movie like I said they
were gonna have way more just teasing a
little bit more of his cousin Miles
Morales he's still a very little kid
they'd both been snapped and come back
after the movie came out I saw some of
you commenting on my Easter egg videos
if they would use that five-year time
jump to explain how Miles Morales could
become a version of spider-man much
sooner because right now he's supposed
to be a
really really a little kid so under
normal circumstances it would just take
four or five more years for him to age
up to the proper age where he'd get the
spider bite and they could do a Miles
Morales live action spider-man movie but
per this explanation they had both been
snapped so he's still a really little
kid in 2023 so it's still gonna be a
long time before they get to live action
Miles Morales spider-man but I wouldn't
be surprised if we get some more Easter
eggs for that during spider-man 3 right
now Kevin Feige says that he doesn't
have any plans to do the Miles Morales
character but he's not completely
counting him out of Marvel phase 5
number 10 there was a flashback deleted
scene of MJ coming back from Washington
the big Washington catastrophe Eider man
homecoming where Peter and Aunt May have
to drive her home and it was gonna serve
as more of a basis for their
relationship because they pretty much
pick up the movie and he really likes
her but they didn't really establish
that at the end of spider-man homecoming
so this was just gonna be some more
connective tissue for that and explain
why her home life was so bad and why she
acts the way she does being so brutally
honest with everyone but they did have
that confession during the Tower of
London that they used for comedy so if
you thought it was weird that they were
so into each other romantically at the
beginning of the movie when they really
weren't there at the end of spider-man
far from home
and it's only been a little while since
everyone's just come back from the snap
there were scenes during the movie that
sort of established that relationship a
little bit better 9 there was a
completely deleted montage to-do-list
scene at the beginning of the film these
were all part of the New York scenes
Peter had to go get his passport renewed
because of the five-year time jump a lot
of these scenes were actually in the
trailer so you're probably familiar with
a lot of this stuff 8 there was him
taking down the Manfredi mob in the iron
spider suit that was definitely in all
the trailers the Manfredi mob is led by
Silvio Manfredi who is Silvermane in the
comics so it's a pretty big spider-man
villain that they could do in the future
but the way they're talking about
Silvermane and the mob in these scenes
they just sound like regular thugs like
you're not gonna see cyborgs Silvermane
anytime soon in a spider-man film the
director did say that he wanted to use
Kraven the hunter as one of the villains
of the third film the Manfredi mob does
have a vendetta against spider-man now
and now that they know who he is is
pretty easy to explain that they would
hire him or other criminals would hire
Kraven the hunter taking out a hit on
spire
man seven towards the middle of the film
when Mysterio is fighting spider-man
using all those illusions against him
trying to make him lose his mind there
were a bunch of deleted scenes of extra
illusions and things that he showed him
this is their big challenge during that
was to make it seem different from the
Doctor Strange multiverse montage scene
where you have Doctor Strange being
pushed through all these different crazy
dimensions there was an illusion
Mysterio created where his cape gets
really big and creates a monster the
cape monster then chases spider-man
across a giant chessboard on two giant
piano keys
six Mysterio creates a giant spider that
chases Peter there were a whole bunch of
different masks that he winds up showing
him like you have the Marvel Zombies
Iron Man moment there was a whole bunch
more of that stuff 5 Peter got stuck in
a giant spiderweb that then starts
attacking him the actual spiderweb
itself starts attacking him for you
probably heard about this there was a
new Captain America cameo from the
Falcon and he wasn't going to be in his
Captain America costume but at the time
that they previewed that show when they
came out at Comic Con did the big Marvel
phase 4 panel Falcon in the Winter
Soldier by the time he'd already done a
costume test for the Captain America
version of his new Falcon suit it kind
of looks like this this isn't an exact
match but it's pretty close to what its
gonna look like during that TV series 3
because there was so much going on in
London they talked about including the
Captain Britain character Captain
Britain himself was actually a big
Easter egg during Avengers endgame if
you remember during the 1970s trip where
they go back to the shield base he runs
into Peggy Carter Peggy Carter is
talking about a quote-unquote Agent
Braddock who is Captain Britain in the
comics so they've already canonized that
character he exists somewhere in this
universe but we don't know how old he is
we don't know who's playing him so at
some point in the future we'll probably
see him and they'll pay that Easter egg
off too there were a whole bunch of
Maria Hill deleted scenes early in the
film they were meant to take place and
sort of bridge the gap after this
funeral scene where they're all together
for the last time like they have the
funny moment where Nick Fury says I saw
you at the funeral I've thought about
introducing myself but I didn't because
that would have been inappropriate just
sort of shining a light on the big
question everyone had like why doesn't
it Fury no Spider Man they were both as
the funeral together remember the
factory that Mysterio uses to trick Nick
Fury in spider-man
makes it look like they're shield
offices they've been operating out of
the early Maria Hill scenes bridging the
gap would have taken place in her
offices there with her just catching up
with a mountain of paperwork not really
sure what to do in like Nick Fury being
about five years behind on all the big
news she gets the news about Tony
Stark's will and giving the Edith
glasses to spider-man Nick Fury telling
her that they have to go on this mission
and her not wanting to deal with Peter
Parker spider-man like I don't want to
have to deal with that kid in Nick Fury
just giving her the stink eye until she
came along but the interesting thing is
is that Cobie Smulders said that when
she was performing all these scenes
Marvel did not tell her that she was
going to be a Skrull at the end of the
film so anytime you see Maria hill
during the movie on-screen interacting
with the other characters its Cobie
Smulders thinking that she is the real
version of Maria hill and not knowing
that is going to be a big twist at the
end in number one the second alternate
ending and probably the bigger one is
that during this final boss fight
between spider-man and Mysterio on
London Tower Bridge Peter was actually
going to out his own secret identity
ripped the mask off and reveals to the
world I'm Peter Parker I've been
spider-man for a couple years now it was
supposed to be a much more direct easter
egg for the ending of the original Iron
Man movie where he outs his own secret
identity I am Iron Man and obviously a
big callback to Avengers endgame in the
way he went out
[Music]
in the theater we all saw that they did
a complete 180 on that idea Peter Parker
doesn't want have anything to do with
people knowing his secret identity until
Mysterio forcibly outs him using Jay
jonah Jameson in The Daily Bugle dotnet
cannot wait to see more of Jay John
Jameson during spider-man 3 all the
stuff with the Fantastic Four Easter
eggs the Nick Fury post-credit scene
teasing all the cosmic Marvel phase
forced up all that was relatively
similar if there any deleted scenes that
you guys heard about that I didn't
include in the video just let me know in
the comments let me know also what's
your favorite deleted scene what do you
think about that alternate I am
spider-man I am Iron Man moment it would
have been cool but I think that the
version that they went with in the
actual movie is better Peter Parker can
now go on the run John wick 3style
everybody versus Peter Parker in
spider-man 3 they're dropping the movie
on digital I think at the end of the
month right after the big Marvel phase 4
d23 panel there is a rumor that they're
gonna be showing off footage from some
of their Marvel phase 4 movies at that
so whatever it is that they drop I will
totally make videos and Easter eggs
about but leave all your requests in the
comments below
everybody click here to learn about the
Red Hulk scene from Avengers endgame
that we almost got and click here to
learn about the Fantastic Four Easter
Egg in spider-man far from home thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]